all right let's start today with
Democratic presidential debate number
four which took place last night on CNN
a roughly three-hour affair I did stream
commentary for about the first 45
minutes of it before
CNN shut it down Sam Cedars stream
getting shut down about 90 minutes in or
so according to the tweets that I got
turns out CNN is much more aggressive
than anybody else when it comes to
preventing any commentary streams about
their debates but we have time today to
talk about it and in general one would
expect that over time you will have
fewer participants in primary debates
although the Democratic debates so far
sort of going in the opposite direction
after getting down from 20 to 10 or 11
we were back up to 12 participants
yesterday and it was a complete and
total mess which is one of the things
that I'll talk about I decided I'm not
going to play any clips from the debate
in this segment two reasons really one I
want to have more time for commentary in
a three hour debate you know there
weren't really these short moments that
lend themselves to highlights per se and
in any case there are a whole bunch of
you know 15 20 minute highlight videos
online and CNN is being so punitive when
it comes to copyright we will just be
doing my thoughts on it and you know
check out the clips later widely
available online so let's talk about
that first thing I mentioned once again
debates with twelve people on the stage
aren't good that was again confirmed
last night and I don't want to be labor
this but yet again as if we didn't know
you don't really get a chance for much
depth when you have 12 people on stage
unless you just straight-up ignore some
of them for long periods of time which
actually did also happen yesterday which
is logical in a sense in that you know
there's a big conversation right now on
health care for example between the
Bernie Warren view and the Biden view
which is different but then also within
Bernie Warren because their positions
are also different and that was a topic
we'll talk about and for a while
everybody else was just sort of ignored
so it's like I get why they're doing
that
at the same time we should just have
fewer people on the stage that's what
would really make the most sense now
important going in especially as we get
this far into the primary where the
positions of the candidates are really
mostly known they may not be known to
every voter but there aren't really
secrets where candidates have not yet
told us their positions on certain
issues it's important to understand the
context is one where debates rarely move
polling in any significant way and when
they do it's often not permanent if it's
up unless you really mess up in which
case you could do permanent damage to
yourself and that's been the theme for
the first three debates example first
debate the big kill shot that got a ton
of attention and play the next day was
Kamala Harris going after Joe Biden that
was either the first or second debate it
got her a spike in the polling
immediately but then that eroded over
the 10 to 14 days that followed and
Kamala Harris went right back to where
she was so the positive you know gotcha
moments only seem to work in the short
term with debates and then things
regularize another example Joe Biden Joe
Biden has had terrible debates mostly
his first and second the third one he
was rather the first and third were not
very good in the second one he actually
did okay
because he was just attacked even in
irrational ways that made him look like
a martyr quite frankly and he ended up
doing OK in that debate Joe Biden has
generally performed poorly and he has
had a permanent decline in the polls so
again
case in point the debates tend not to
permanently move polling very much
unless you do poorly so what I was
interested in watching was going to be
number one does Bernie Sanders go after
Elizabeth Warren we talked about the
mathematical complexities of how does
Bernie get back into the running for
being in first place he's now pretty
significantly behind both Elizabeth
Warren and Joe Biden and the
complexities mathematically are that the
people that Bernie could attack both
Biden and Warren their supporters prefer
in other words Biden supporters
prefer Warren over Bernie and Warren
supporters prefer Biden over Bernie so
by attacking them it's not clear that
Bernie actually helps himself so this
was a question does Bernie go after
Warren and we'll talk about that I
tweeted yesterday that he likely
wouldn't I said that the more likely
scenario was that Bernie would draw some
mild distinctions from Warren but that
nothing would really change and this is
basically how it went and we'll get more
into that momentarily another element I
was watching for does Joe Biden seem
more energized not an analysis of his
policy but does he seem this shrunken
slowed down Biden or does he seem more
energized he was more energized to some
degree last night compared to his just
terrible prior performances unclear that
it will change very much Elizabeth
Warren who now has almost Co frontrunner
status with Biden was definitely more of
a target a number of people on stage
going after her the focus of more
attacks and disagreements which we'll
get to she weathered some of them okay
less well with others including
questions around health care and I'll
get to that we also wanted to pay
attention to how do other candidates go
after or not go after Biden on the
hunter Biden stuff right even if you
don't believe the conspiracy theory that
is being parodied by Trump and the
people around him regarding Joe Biden
and Ukraine and that's all it is a
conspiracy theory without evidence you
can still be critical of that $50,000 a
month Consulting position that hunter
Biden had with the Ukrainian gas company
and there was a question as to how would
the other candidates go after Biden for
that the answer was not that much there
really wasn't that much discussion about
it Biden did get asked about it his
response was pretty pathetically
wishy-washy and muddled and uninspiring
basically changing the subject and not
really addressing it and that was mostly
that foreign policy foreign policy has
been a weak point not just in the
debates but it's a weak point for many
of the candidates who don't really
demonstrate I don't want to say they
don't have the knowledge because they
may have it somewhere in there but
they've not demonstrated deep knowledge
on foreign Paul
see does anyone actually propose
prescriptions on foreign policy instead
of just criticizing Trump there wasn't
that much the most discussed foreign
policy topic yesterday was Syria and the
Kurds understandably almost everybody on
the stage was against the haphazard
withdrawal or at least the way that
Trump did it they were opposed to tulsi
gabbard sort of waffled on it we know
that this is her position she took a
position that the entire problem is not
Trump withdrawing its regime-change wars
and endless wars which is a major
problem with American foreign policy but
it's myopic and simplistic when it comes
to this particular issue as well but
that's been her talking point on most
foreign policy issues she's staked that
out there's a slice of the left that
likes it and right now it's gotten her
0.8 percent support from Democratic
primary voters but other than that
either disagreement with the way that
withdrawal was done or with the
withdrawal period the other candidates
did take the opportunity to distance
themselves from Tulsi gabbard's position
Pete Buddha judge version for example
said that she's just straight-up wrong
about it but it was a relatively small
part of the debate the first question
they made the right decision because
there were 12 people on stage to skip
opening statements which I loved they
made the wrong decision to open the
debate with a question about what do you
think about impeachment which was a
complete waste of time basically
everybody's for impeachment Tulsi
Gabbard not really for it
Pete Buddha judge a little worried about
what the consequences may be but we knew
that nothing useful was learned from
that question it took up about 20
minutes or more it provided an
opportunity for some of the candidates
to grandstand and it was really really
lame speaking of lame and cringe-worthy
billionaire Tom Steyer who effectively
bought his way into the debate was
totally cringe worthy his first
opportunity to speak he tried he went
directly to an applause line where the
audience of course has been told
basically to shut the eff up and not
make noise and very few people reacted
and it was just downhill from there for
steyr contributing noting his presence
was totally superfluous in every way and
unfortunately I believe he's qualified
for the fifth debate Elizabeth Warren
had a particularly weak moment last
night and it was when she was answering
the question will taxes go up under your
health care plan I don't want to repeat
myself again and again and again but
I've already addressed many times a
variety of ways in which candidates
could answer this question and she
unfortunately repeated some of the same
talking points multiple times including
some version of I will not sign a bill
into law that doesn't lower costs for
middle-class families sort of a strange
double negative and really the answer is
I mean listen we know what the answer is
you have total health care costs taxes
are a component of a single-payer plan
but in total costs will go down Bernie
actually handled this pretty well
yesterday Bernie has also totally missed
the mark on this question Bernie said in
clear terms total costs will go down you
get rid of co-pays you get rid of
premiums you get rid of coinsurance all
of that stuff you add a payroll tax it
will be mostly it will be
disproportionately increased for
corporations and for the rich mostly
everybody will pay a little bit but your
total costs will go down it's the truth
and it's a perfectly reasonable way to
do it because people's costs aren't zero
now now there's some conflict about the
math of that statement in terms of some
of the claims Bernie has made and that's
okay we're figuring it out but in the
end
Bernie messaged that way better last
night and Elizabeth Warren fell short
and she was vulnerable as a result of it
multiple candidates saying why can't you
just answer the question not her best
moment last night in what was overall a
pretty good performance Andrew yang's
Andrew Yang's performance Andrew Yang's
followers have been tweeting to me
saying Andrew yang destroyed it he's
about to break into the top three now I
didn't really see it that way
Andrew yang did go after Elizabeth
Warren for not adopting his thousand
dollar-a-month
Universal basic income proposal she said
well I want to increase Social Security
payments it was a nice attempt by Andrew
yang to get some face time with the
presumptive ko frontrunner at this point
Elizabeth Warren I don't think it's
gonna make much of an impression or
impact polling Bernie's health came up
of course having a heart attack a couple
of weeks ago
Bernie handled it as well as you can
while standing up on a stage and
claiming that you're fine his voice and
his energy seemed basically back to
normal so that was good I don't think he
did any damage to himself when that
topic came up Kamala Harris brought
another one of her gotcha attempts when
she asked Elizabeth Warren will you join
me in calling for Trump to be banned on
Twitter and Warren said no and it was
sort of an anticlimactic gotcha moment
Harris tried to be shocked no you won't
but it was a pretty weak gotcha
attempt there's way bigger fish to fry
and Kamala Harris has effectively done
unless like in the next month she can
double her support from you know 5% to
10% the last question of the night was
also a throwaway tell us about a
surprising friendship that you have with
someone real waste of time and I know
some people in my audience will say no
no here's why that was actually an
interesting question it was a waste of
time I want to hear about policy overall
takeaways another dog and pony show
component a big part of it
relatively few new policy details were
discussed I don't expect any big changes
in polling except Bernie looking
generally healthy might help him recover
a little bit of what he's lost in the
last couple of weeks
Biden seeming slightly higher energy
maybe will help him recover a little bit
as well no one really failed but the
people that are polling you knows if one
to two percent I don't see that they're
going to be doing any better as a result
of this debate Bernie did pretty well
with the questions he was given Biden
again given that Biden is the sort of
slowdown Biden he did pretty well given
the questions he was given although he
fumbled when he was asked about the
hunter Biden thing
obviously Biden supporters won't like
the content of what Bernie said Bernie
supporters won't like the content of
what Biden said but they both did well
enough to not do damage the candidates I
thought overall sounded more rehearsed
and less genuine than in Prior debates
as if they're now being guided more by
polling and calculated politics
sadly although very often that's where
it gets to at this point in the race
bottom line is that we can't keep having
12 people on the stage it's just
terrible I mean what does Amy Klobuchar
think about impeachment what does Huli
on Castro think about Syria well what
what why is tulsi gabbard not fully
behind impeachment I mean it's like who
cares right they have no chance and I
want to get into depth with the people
that do have a shot a fifth debate is on
November 20th the new qualification
requirements are three percent in four
or more approved polls or five percent
in two or more early primary state polls
and a hundred and sixty five thousand
donations now as of right now we are
like a full month out from that next
debate there are already eight people
qualified for that debate so we may end
up again with ten people just not
conducive to good conversation right now
the people qualified for debate number
five are Biden Sanders Warren Harris
Budaj
Tom Steyer again Andrew yang and Cory
Booker so we already are going to have
eight people on stage last thing I
continue to be generally concerned about
the idolatry of politicians it's not
just Tulsi and yang there are you know
Bernie idolaters Warren idolaters from
the tweets that I'm getting when I asked
for feedback about debates or polling or
whatever on Twitter people just as a few
civ about some of these candidates as if
these are saviors or near deities and my
position is politicians just aren't the
best period these aren't I would argue
even the types of people that we should
be idolizing and without commenting on
any specific politicians
I would just want to see sort of more
measured analyses than the gushing
praise of pseudo deities that I'm seeing
on Twitter about certain candidates
that's just me I just don't see
politicians in the same light maybe it's
because I do this show and I've met a
lot of these people and it's like these
are just imperfect people with many
flaws and sometimes they have good ideas
on a few issues but I want to hear from
you about that I want to hear from you
about the debate if you're watching on
YouTube please leave a response down
below or send me a tweet at D Pakman I
do want to hear from you make sure
you're following me on Twitter we will
take a quick break and be back with all
the day's news right after this